foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday January 9th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the North Atlantic right whale is a
docile Giant
you're hearing it now in tape from NOAA
Fisheries
but it's endangered and in recent years
its numbers have plunged from an
estimated 481 individuals in 2011 to 340
in 2021.
one cause of this is the whales can
sometimes get tangled up in fishing
lines in particular ropes that connect
lobster traps to buoys floating on the
ocean's surface so conservationists want
to make these traps ropeless but to do
that they'll need new technology and
buy-in from lobstermen with me to talk
about the tech behind this new gear and
how it's being received is our science
and climate reporter Eric neeler hi Eric
great to have you back on the show nice
to be here so let's talk about how some
of these Technologies work firstly for
lobstermen if they don't have buoys on
top of the water to locate their lobster
traps how do they find the cages yeah so
imagine that a lobsterman has a string
of say eight ten maybe even 20 lobster
traps and they're sort of all roped
together and on the very ends of these
ropes are lines that reach to the
surface with two buoys floating on top
and this marks his territory and
hopefully there'll be lobsters crawling
around and they'll smell the bait and go
inside and get trapped in the traps and
they lobsterman wants to bring them up
so normally he would look for his buoy
it may have a colored marking and may
have a number it may be just a floating
jug like a plastic milk jug or a special
design that says okay these are my
lobsters well those ropes can also get
tangled around the right whales that
swim through the area so the idea is to
eliminate the vertical lines that are in
the water
so what they've done is they've figured
out a couple of neat little methods of
putting a buoy on the Trap below as a
lobsterman approaches he's going to send
out an acoustic signal which is in it
received by the device on the lobster
trap
releases
either self-inflatable buoy some other
kind of buoy is going to float to the
surface
and the lobstermen can then pick that up
and bring in his trap line
so going from this very low Tech just
kind of you know painted buoys that tell
you where their cages the traps are on
the bottom of the ocean to very high
tech you know a device that inflates
itself and comes to the surface is that
what we're talking about yeah it's funny
these devices were built by scientific
device firms that were used to supplying
scientists who are studying the oceans
for whether it's climate change or
chemistry the ocean and so they have a
real expertise and getting things to
work underwater and one of the big
problems is you can't really send the
same kind of signals as in the air like
a radio signal right and you can't get
an internet underwater either it's too
dense so you've got to find a different
way so they have these acoustic
signaling devices they've developed for
many years for scientific instruments
that are now being used to help the
fishermen and so they've been testing
these for a couple years and they've
been working out the bugs and they found
a couple of systems that seem to work
actually quite accurately that will
allow the fishermen to retrieve his
lobster traps without having these
vertical lines in the water
the people who are testing this
to the Lobster men the boat captains how
are they finding the tech in these
trials some of the lobstermen feel that
you know it's not their fault that the
whales are dying that it's maybe their
Beach for other reasons or they can't
find their food and so it is very
difficult to pinpoint a connection
between one person's rope and the death
of a whale and so they've been a lot of
fighting back against it through
lobbying and political means and so
forth on the other hand there are also
lobstermen who are looking in the future
and saying you know this problem isn't
going to go away if they can make it
simple and easy and that it won't lose
too much money then maybe we should try
this why are these Technologies
something that are being tested out now
right well for the last few years what's
pushed this technological Drive really
is legal action lawsuits filed by
conservation groups in the Boston area
and judges decision saying the federal
government must protect these whales
under two different federal laws The
Marine Mammal protection act and The
Endangered Species Act and so as a
result the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration NOAA has
devised these trials for this new gear
and so this is really what's been
pushing it is these legal action and a
series of deadlines to find a way to
protect these whales but what happened
in December was members of Congress from
Maine inserted a provision into the
budget bill that would extend the
deadline of any kind of action on these
new rules so we were a bit of a limbo
right now the deadline was going to be
two years now it's going to be out for
several years longer
and so a little bit of the impetus to
get these new technologies off the
ground and perfected has been taken away
I mean apart from the political
questions that remain
difficulties getting people on board
with using these Technologies other
challenges that lobstermen might have to
deal with if they take them on well of
course cost is the big thing these
devices can cost five thousand ten
thousand up to twenty thousand dollars
depending on each device and lobstermen
often have several hundred trap lines
and each one has got 10 traps on them so
the cost is going to go up really
quickly so cost has been one big issue
but also adoption of a new technology
something they're not used to many
fishermen have adopted new technologies
to help them find fish to help them
navigate through rough Seas or see
approaching weather patterns and this
sort of thing but this is really about
harvesting the lobster from the water
and for some part-time fishermen they're
not willing to pay that cost and to
invest the time needed to learn how to
use these devices on the other hand
there's a small and but growing group of
lobstermen who are dedicated to this
they're trying them out there are
several dozen along the east coast and
all the way up to Cape Cod in Maine
who were breaking some new ground they
call themselves the pioneers and they
are really working to get these devices
working they're also hoping that as Noah
goes through the regulations that they
will be allowed to fish in areas that
may be closed now to other sorts of gear
so one of the ways that you can protect
the whales is say well you can't have
any fishermen any lobstering in this
entire Zone unless you have what's
called ropeless gear the fisherman the
lobstermen who are figuring out how to
use that gear may get in a little bit of
an advantage over their neighbors who
are reluctant to adopt the new
technology all right that's our science
reporter Eric neeler thanks for joining
us Eric you're welcome and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing if you want
more Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]